it was meant to be a celebration of
poland's identity and culture
and a chance to honor those who fought
to win her freedom
thousands of people including president
bronislav komorowski converged on warsaw
to mark polish independence day
many wore the national colours of red
and white or dressed as soldiers of the
second world war
but what started peacefully degenerated
into violent chaos as a hardcore
far-right nationalist broke away from
the main procession
[Applause]
slipping down a side street gangs of
youth wearing balaclavas and football
scarves attacked a squat inhabited by
left-wing radicals
the two sides traded missiles and
molotov cocktails before wright police
moved in making several arrests
back in the city center large crowds of
right-wing demonstrators faced off
against security forces
waving polish flags and red flares and
chanting nationalist slogans
as society becomes more liberal many
polls like these say they feel sidelines
and demand the government respect their
traditional values
this sense that poland's conservative
culture is under attack has prompted
increasing outbreaks of right-wing
street violence
as the march continued through the
capital russia's embassy was targeted
symbolic to many poles of the brutal
repression of the soviet era
it was attacked with flares and
firecrackers setting light to a rubbish
bin inside the embassy grounds
only the presence of large numbers of
riot police forming a cordon around the
building prevented further damage
the protesters final target was baby
cellar square
[Music]
a well-known meeting place for young
left-wing students and intellectuals
it's a potent symbol of poland's most
liberal elements
a large arch decorated with bright
colours and artificial flowers
representing tolerance and diversity was
torched by the rioters as police looked
on
this is the third year in a row
independence day has been marred by
violence of this kind
as the fault lines in polish society
continue to deepen it looks unlikely to
be the last
chris wade sky news